the other major story this morning we
are following is the worsening covert 19
crisis
in this country more retail companies
are announcing plans to mandate the
wearings of face coverings amid an
increasing number
of covet 19 infections there are more
than 71
600 coronavirus cases reported on friday
bringing the total number in the u.s
to 3.6 million the u.s death toll stands
at 139
000. in california governor gavin newsom
announced friday he's keeping public
schools and 32 counties
closed when classes resume next month
michael george
is in new york with more on the outbreak
michael good morning
jeff good morning on monday a new york
institution the empire state building
reopens to the public
after being closed for four months but
it will be at 20 percent capacity and
masks will be required
as new york tests reopening much of the
country is facing the consequences
of reopening too early the number of u.s
coronavirus cases broke
more records this week the white house's
coronavirus task force put
18 states in what it's calling the red
zone
and recommends that red zone counties
require masks
according to a task force document
obtained by cbs news
but not made public masks are a
fundamental part
of how we contain and fight the virus
more than half the states already have
mask mandates
in some places police give fines to
people not wearing them
atlanta's mayor made masks mandatory
what the scientists are telling us
is that the right thing to do is to wear
a mask but georgia's governor
is vowing to fight against mask
requirements
in a state where 15 cities have already
passed them
and while we all agree that wearing a
mask is effective
i'm confident that georgians don't need
a mandate to do the right thing
this is going to be brief and in provo
utah the idea of
masks gave this non-socially distanced
crowd at a community meeting
something to boo about this is the exact
opposite of what we need to be doing
we are supposed to be physically
distancing wearing masks
but in florida health officials are
hoping for better news
after days of record-setting case
numbers eight of miami-dade county's 25
hospitals have intensive care units full
public health officials say what happens
next is up to the public
we're hoping against hope that people
are getting the message that they're
changing their behavior
if we don't see that by monday tuesday
then yeah it's possible that we may have
to enact
further measures throughout the south
the dire situation is felt first
by doctors on the front lines it doesn't
stop and we don't know when it's going
to stop at this point
in texas a sad reality refrigerator
trucks positioned and ready
to handle the dead many places including
california have rescinded orders that
allowed businesses to reopen
after a surge in the los angeles area
it's a likely trend
as long as the virus remains out of
control
and here in new york city phase four
reopening starts on monday but because
of how bad things are in the rest of the
country
the plans have been scaled back gyms
malls museums and indoor dining remain
off limits
indefinitely dana all right michael
thank you